the fake mcdreamy's back aka me
i'm gonna be watching my second episode
of grey's anatomy alongside you guys
let's get it started
turn up the tv a massive train wreck
occurred just
outside of seattle minutes ago 9-1-1 we
just worked at 30-hour shifts
i don't have any clean underwear the
vancouver-bound train was
that's crazy they worked a 30-hour shift
and they can get paige to go back
hello i seem to be a little bit drunk
i was off-duty so was i anybody else
half in the bottle
no i don't get why she would come in to
her shift
if she's drunk that's not helpful to
anybody
and if she starts performing any kind of
medical procedures while
under the influence that's not good for
patients that's not good for her
it's just a subpar solution so i don't
really understand what she's even
doing there she should be making a
little love
with mcdreamy
[Music]
was that a not yes do we know what about
no
am i invisible how much roman i feel
like this isn't a medical show anymore
it's just a romance show
whoa what is that that
okay fine maybe it's the second worst
that was crazy so are you gonna pull
this pull out of us any time soon
touch uncomfortable i'm sorry we can't
do that until we get a better look at
what's going on internally but i assure
you
we will work as quickly as possible
they're taking this very
not seriously and a lot of humor with a
pole
jammed into two people's bodies whoa
that's all i can really say right now
something that i think needs to be done
immediately is to give them some sort of
back support so that
they don't get fatigued and tired and
start slouching because if they are to
slouch
when they get tired and they obviously
will get tired they can do more internal
damage with that pole going through them
you are
drunk go get yourself a banana bag iv
put it in your arm and then find me
do not speak to any more patients do not
practice any medicine
iv drips do not stop hangovers this is
why so many people are opening these iv
drip spas especially in vegas i see that
happen a lot and they promise you that
it's going to block or cure your
hangover an
iv will hydrate you the same
that you can hydrate yourself by
drinking some water or drinking some
fluids with electrolytes in them now
that being said it's going to be a
little bit quicker
but then again you're also increasing
risks because you're opening
a hole in your skin to get that iv in
something to mention about hangovers
is that it's not all about dehydration a
hangover is like a catch-all term for
all sorts of symptoms nausea
vomiting fatigue dizziness a dry mouth
yes hydration may help some of these
things but it's a complicated process
that has a lot of things going on in it
just giving yourself hydration
is not the sole answer no no no we're
fine honey
yeah some redneck tried to outrun the
train honey and the train slammed into
his ass
and then it rolled it hurt oh no no
no no no that dude is toast he was doing
sutures it looked like
above her eyebrow no doctor would
perform sutures like that
keeping your hands elevated like that
from a lowered position and doing
sutures
you're gonna get fatigued so quickly and
your hands are gonna start shaking and
you won't be able to do it right you
always need to be above the given
situation where are you going
i'm taking your friend for an x-ray um
no offense little boy but uh you look
like my oldest son
and he's nothing but trouble yvonne shut
up what
i said no offense i'm just saying are
you sure you're the doctor
i get that all the time what are you
doing trying to insert my banana bag
which sounds vaguely dirty but it is a
banana bag is just an iv
bag with normal saline which is fluids
with electrolytes in them there's also
some vitamins in there generally this is
given to people who are chronic
alcoholics because they're
usually nutrient depleted giving a
banana bag to someone who's healthy and
had a few drinks
pretty much useless just have some water
and give it some time
his legs what about them
[Music]
they're both left
[Music]
find the man's leg yang find it now yes
sir
they got the wrong leg and why did she
say it only then
these people are still alive they're
still making small talk
poe's tamponading the wound as far as we
can see when she says that the
wound is being tamponed by the pole
it means that it's exerting pressure and
actually preventing them from bleeding
that's why if you ever get stabbed with
something it's never ideal to just pull
it out automatically until you have
medical care
that object whatever it is is putting
pressure to stop
the bleeding what if we move one of the
patients off the pole to get the saw in
there
then we can hold the pole steady in the
other one move it
very slowly and repair the damage as we
go who
which would you move with her aortic
injuries
her chances of survival are extremely
slim no matter what we do i don't really
buy the realism of this
the aorta is a pulsatile vessel
meaning that every time the heart beats
the aorta moves
so if you have a metal pole that's going
through the aorta and has cut it open
there's no way that pole is putting that
much pressure that it's
preventing her from bleeding out unless
it's like crushing it or compressing it
in such a weird way
so basically whoever you move doesn't
stand a chance
why can't they just cut the pole from in
between them and then separate so how do
you choose
how do you decide who gets to live
you're a cute doctor
cute doctors get to call me by my first
name
bonnie hmm okay
oh my dreamy can you feel me rubbing
your foot
could you try to wiggle your toes mr
maynard
are they moving yes they are good
that's good right yes it is what about
me
am i moving
yes
that's probably one of the situations
it's okay to lie to my patient
is there any chance that we can get out
of here sometime this year
well the lab's backed up and so is
radiology and i can't discharge your
friend until i'm certain she doesn't
have any internal injuries
nowadays we decide if someone has
internal bleeding with an ultrasound
called a fast scan
if i don't find this leg the chief is
going to cut me from this program
and i cannot go back home burke it is
too sunny in los angeles it's sunny
every day
i don't understand what she expects does
she think that the the chief is gonna be
like you couldn't find this leg in the
rubble
so that's it you're cut from the program
i don't understand what her thinking is
this
supposed to be a comedic aspect is she
being sarcastic in order to operate on
mr maynard
we have to separate you two in order to
do that
we have to move you backwards off the
[Music]
pole
can't just pull the pole out of both of
us well if we did that
we would both start bleeding very
quickly too quickly
right now the pole is plugging the
wounds once removed
the organs will shift and there is a
great deal of damage
so if you move me don't die
you're being ridiculous you're gonna be
fine do you hear me i hear you
but we still have to sign the forms
unless you want our son to end up with
my mom
[Music]
[Laughter]
how long have you two been together
since third grade
oh we're not lovers we're best friends
oh
we just wanted our kids to have two
parents so we got a sperm donor
the same donor so your babies are
brother and sister
oh how cool is that oh my gosh
okay who writes this stuff
yvonne it's your phone yvonne
keep on
yvonne looks like she passed out okay
first thing you do during your code blue
chest compressions chest compression
chest compressing chest compression
but also before you call a code blue you
got to check for a pulse because code
blue means someone's heart has stopped
and just because someone's unconscious
it doesn't mean they're a code blue so
my man needed to go right up there to
the carotid or to the femoral artery or
to the radial artery this is usually the
best place
and feel if there's a pulse there's no
pulse yelling for help while doing
chest compressions she's lost too much
blood she's been bleeding for hours
there's no blood she's not bleeding she
was bleeding internally
what's interesting about the abdominal
cavity is that the back portion the
posterior portion which we call the
retroperitoneal area
it can actually store a lot of blood
so you can be having a very slow leak of
blood into that area and not really know
that you're bleeding out
the one thing that makes this less
likely is that she was talking she was
moving around
generally if you're losing blood you
start having symptoms like you feel
fatigued your eyes are closing you feel
like you're going to faint or pass
out your blood pressure starts dropping
you can even be having some abdominal
pain
because blood is a natural irritant to
the abdominal cavity so you start
feeling
pain and then once we do our exam we'll
note that you have an acute abdomen
we would do an ultrasound or a cat scan
find the bleeding and then take you in
for what we call an explorative
laparotomy
where we literally open up your stomach
by stomach i mean the skin
of your abdomen look around check the
entire intestines find where you're
bleeding
fix that area put everything back in so
you back up and get you
up and moving again but in this case
she's lost so much blood that she went
to cardiac arrest
meaning her heart stopped now he's doing
the advanced cardiac life support
uh procedure where he's giving
epinephrine he's doing chest
compressions
he's helping her breathe with the bag
and hopefully trying to get her pulse
back and get her heart beating again oh
no no i'm sorry
[Music]
time of death 251
[Music]
what about her we cannot just abandon
her we have an obligation
come on come on there was too much
damage there's never anything we can do
we have to let her go
349. one of the most difficult parts
about medicine is triage
knowing who you can help in a given
moment and
knowing where to use resources when
they're very limited
some of those decisions are
heart-wrenching they're incredibly
difficult to make
at times it feels like you're playing
god and it's putting you in the most
unfair situations but you have to do
your best
given what limited resources you have
and what limited information you have
to make the best possible and fairest
decision i applaud all first responders
in these types of
mass casualty situations uh growing up
in new york city thinking about 9 11
what that must have been like uh for
people who
were working in the local new york city
hospitals it scares me it blows my mind
all at the same time
i've trained in level one trauma centers
during my
medical school time and just
having a few people come in with gunshot
wounds or knife wounds or bicycle
accidents
those are incredibly stressful
situations you never know what to expect
you always have to be thinking quickly
on your feet
so then to imagine what it must be like
when hundreds of people or even
thousands of people are coming in
wow so huge thank you to all the people
that are have ever been involved or may
ever be involved in those types of
situations in the future we really
respect you and thank you for your
service
did she suffer
no her interest again these
conversations don't happen in the open
this is not right
better get cleaned up rounds in
five minutes today has been
i don't get it they work 30 hours they
come in for an emergency look
look like they worked for another 12
hours they've been working for 42 now
they're going to morning rounds
do they ever get time off oh man you
guys recommended a doozy here
it presented an interesting situation uh
unfortunate
for the patient that died kind of shows
you that doctors are sometimes put into
really tight spots where
they have to use limited information
limited resources and sometimes
let one life go in order to save another
and that's a very
very very unfair and tight situation
that we find ourselves in
that's what we asked for when we decided
to go into medicine and that's why it's
a beautiful field and we get so much
admiration put upon us as doctors
because we have to make those decisions
i like grey's anatomy it's a fun show
there's a lot of drama in it so if you
have some more episodes
maybe ones that are more medical and
less like oh my god mcdreamy
does he love me does he love me not like
i know that's important but i would love
to comment on some more medical aspects
of the show
drop it down below in the comments hit
that subscribe button
and the notification bell so that you
know when all my videos are coming up
as always stay happy and healthy that's
why
if you ever get stabbed with something
it's not ideal to just pull it out
until you have medical care around you
because
what even was that